[Music]
you invest your life in trying to change
the past
this is like banging your head on a wall
which is not going to break anyway it's
your head which will break
what you can change you do not change
what you can craft
you do not do it because all your energy
goes into
banging your head on something that's
already over this is not easy time for
people
this is a time we must understand our
karma
our present karma is most important our
life is ticking away
the final tick mark will come later but
right now it is ticking away
all right if you know this you have no
time to do
anything that doesn't truly matter to
you for your happiness
to live happily and peacefully here the
most fundamental thing is
believe nation welcome back a very very
very special guest to the channel
sadhguru welcome aboard i must get him
so he's got a new book out called karma
we're going to link it up in the
description below
it just came out amazing new book and
i'm excited to dive into this because
karma is one of those words that i think
in north america has taken on
a totally different meaning than what
the original meaning is i think a lot of
us think of it as
well if i do something bad then karma's
going to come and get me
and do something bad towards me some
kind of punishment what
is karma for you uh
the word karma literally means action
when we say action as human beings
both in our wakefulness and sleep
we are performing four dimensions of
action physical action
mental action emotional action
and energetic action these four
activities are always happening
whether we want to do it we don't want
to do it there's no choice it is always
happening
it's being done by us
so now if you look at it how much of
this is being done
consciously in 24 hours time for
most human beings it's well below one
percent
so this is like you uh i won't give a
truck in your hands let me give you a
bicycle okay because that's dangerous
for everybody else
uh if you're riding a bicycle and let's
say 10 minutes you're riding
9.9 minutes you are
riding with your eyes closed you know
what's the consequence
so this is what is happening to people
and because of this
they think something else from somewhere
else is hitting them
this idea of like what you mentioned
about uh reward and punishment system
this comes from old belief systems of
heaven and hell
heaven and hell is supposed to be the
ultimate reward and punishment
on the way there are many minor heavens
and health
like this people go on so this comes
from belief system that
this will happen but that's not the way
life has worked
it is just that everything that we do
there is a
residual impact upon us this residual
impact creates a consequence
this consequence it's up to us whether
we
go through it joyfully or miserably
whether we violently react to it
or consciously respond to it these are
our choices
if you do not exercise these choices
karma will crush you
if you exercise these choices you can
ride the wheel of karma
one who rides a bicycle he experiences
it wonderfully
one who falls under its wheels
definitely is not a pleasant experience
so karma is just like this instead of
learning to ride the
karmic wheel people are thinking it is
coming and hitting them from somewhere
else
no no when you misunderstand your own
hand
to be the hand of the divine or
something
then you become very delusional and you
pay the price for it
so the intention of the book is to bring
the right perspective to karma
because this is the most dynamic way to
exist in the world
that my life is my karma simply means my
life is my making
so when you see that my life is my
making
then you will see how you want to be
right now
people have taken various dispositions
let's say
somebody is nasty they think this is
because of another time and of course
there's a whole lot of psycho analysis
telling them this is because your father
abused you
at that time you're abusing everybody
else in the universe right now
you know these kind of explanations are
going on especially if you suffered
abuse from somebody
you must understand you should never
abuse anybody else
but that is not the way we respond we
think if somebody abuses us once
we must abuse million people million
times over this has been the consequence
because
it is a violent reaction to whatever is
happening within us
whatever is our karma is like the past
it has happened till today what has
happened till today should be your
platform to stand up on
and do your dance of today but instead
of that it is working like a quicksand
that people are sinking into it so
what is uh yesterday what is past
you can never fix it there's nothing to
fix there because it doesn't exist
what is today you can only experience it
there's really nothing else to do you
can only experience it the way it is
but what is next moment and tomorrow you
have to create it
you you invest your life in trying to
change the past
this is like banging your head on a wall
which is not going to break anyway it's
your head which will break
what you can change you do not change
what you can craft
you do not do it because all your energy
goes into
banging your head on something that's
already over
can you explain the cover of this box so
this came in
and first it it was beautifully wrapped
i almost didn't want to open it
because it was so beautifully packaged
and put together but but i had to so i
can get through it for this interview
what is the symbolism here what does
this mean to you why did you pick this
design for the cover
this is a a mural in one of our
meditation halls in the east yoga center
in
india this is uh some people say this is
the largest mural in the world i don't
know
for sure but some people claim it is the
largest one
so we designed this mural to depict
the five dimensions upon which a human
being can work
when i say five dimensions see the
entire physical world is made up of five
elements
in the yogic senses uh water
earth water fire air and space
these are the five these five dimensions
only with this five the entire entire
universe is made
so is your body so the fundamental of
yogic sciences
is in this which is called as bhuta that
means
one thing is to cleanse the elements in
your system another thing is to have
mastery
or these elements if you have mastery
over the elements within your system
then your body your mind your energies
everything functions the way you want so
you don't do anything about it
because you're not taking care of the
ingredients the final cooking is a mess
so the yoga the basis the foundational
practices of yoga are called as bhuta
well when i say yoga in north america
well it means something else
that's not what i'm talking about when
we say yogic sciences
the most basic of these practices are
buddhisti
so this is a depiction of buddha shuddhi
working with
earth working with water working with
air
working with fire and space so this is
working with air
this imagery of a yogi hanging upside
down from a tree
and working upon the air in the system
when i say air in the system right now
everybody understands
particularly with the pandemic everybody
understands how important it is to
breathe properly
so it's not just about the breath every
cell in the body
has a certain amount of air in it
invested
so generally we see that about
70 to 72 percent is water about 12
is earth about six to eight percent is
air the remaining part is fire and
space so this six to eight percent of
air
has a significant role to play in our
life
the way you think and the way you
breathe are very
directly connected today modern science
also is acknowledging this
that uh you know suppose you this is
something that we
do in the yogic system that if you
simply sit here and think about
mountains
if you take your breath it will be one
way you think about a tiger
it'll be another way you think about
ocean it'll be another way because
your thought and your breath are so
directly connected
well at least this everybody knows if
they become
if their thoughts become little fearful
you know their breath
goes into a certain state of
exaggeration or
aberration will happen so breath and
thought process is very directly
connected
right now what people call as happiness
and unhappiness is essentially
in your thoughts if what you want is
happening you are happy
in your thoughts what you don't want is
happening you're unhappy
so in this way for your happiness
to live happily and peacefully here the
most fundamental thing is
your breath should happen in such a way
naturally your chemistry will function
in such a way
that your thought process will be the
way you want it
this is as simple as that if your
thought and emotion happen the way you
want
well you will be joyful there's no
question about it the
life around you the world around you may
not happen the way you want always
especially right now it doesn't happen
but uh
your thought and your emotion is
happening your way you're joyful by your
nature
so in that context air or mastery over
air in the system is very important so
for karma because
people are thinking their happiness and
unhappiness their joys and miseries are
all their karma
they're being punished from somewhere no
you're misunderstanding your own hand
to be some other hand maybe hand of god
or something no no no
your hand is slapping you in the face
and you think somebody else is hitting
you
is there a solution for this unless you
realize this is my hand
you can't stop it this is karma and what
i love about
the book but all of your teachings is
this is an easy book to read
even though it's it's talking about what
seems
to be a complex topic it's it's very
easy to read and you have a
a fun way of explaining things even when
i went to missed a guy in toronto and
there's
thousands of people in the audience when
you sit down to think about
a lecture it's usually boring but
at yours you're you're laughing you're
joking you're talking about joy and
dancing
talk to me about the intent of of
writing the book in a way that
is easy to consume that is not doesn't
require
a level of sophistication to understand
see when you speak
suppose i speak to you or you speak to
me or you speak to somebody
if the purpose of speech is not to
communicate i think you
should just shut up so we speak in such
a way
that nobody understands you better not
speak
it's important when you speak to a group
of people
you speak in a way that they understand
so right now in the name of spiritual
process in the name of religion what's
happened is
simple aspects of life has been made
mystical my life's work is to make
mystical
approachable and simple because this is
important otherwise what's the point of
any teaching i'll give you a teaching
that you can never understand
what is the point of that nonsense i
call it nonsense
if i give you a teaching it should be of
some use to you
otherwise what is the point of that
this is not a book that you carry on
your head
this is a book that you can implement in
your life because that's what is
important
you must live life you don't have to
carry the information of life on your
head
so the idea of for me the idea of
speaking and writing is not to create a
scripture that nobody understands
but to create a you know when people ask
me
what do i read because uh most of the
time if i read i read ace tricks or
dennis the menace you know all those
comics are dead now
unfortunately nobody is creating new
ones but these are the wisest things i
read
i didn't read any scriptures because
most of this stuff is written in such a
way which is endless debate
i don't want a debate i want solutions
to life
my work is to offer solutions to people
not to cause one
great intellectual circus i love it
let's talk about the timing you've done
so many books
and karma seems to be such a powerful
concept
why is now the time that you decide to
release the book on karma
well uh in india we have not released
that book here
just before the first wave of pandemic
in 2020 in the month of
january we released a book called death
an inside story of death
so uh well just after that the pandemic
broke out
at that time nobody had any idea when we
released the book in
third week of january i think so people
started saying satguru did you foresee
pandemic did you do this see pandemic or
no pandemic
anyway people are dying it's not people
means not other people
you and me are dying right now it's so
the process is on
one day it will be complete well i'll
bless you with a long life but we will
die all right
we are mortal why is this so important
is see if we do not understand we have a
limited amount of time
we will have lot of time to do foolish
things in our life
if we understand we are on a limited
lease of time as we sit here
our life is ticking away it's not time
which is ticking away our life is
ticking away
the final tick mark will come later but
right now it is ticking away all right
if you know this you have no time to do
anything
that doesn't truly matter to you you
will not do anything that
that you don't truly care for if you me
and everybody starts doing only what
truly
what we truly care for this is a
wonderful world to live
the problem is too many people are doing
things that they don't care for
having said that why karma now
see right now what i see is while in
india
the pandemic is unfortunately taken on a
different
level of distress
well even there i've been talking the
first wave of pandemic india handled it
very well
oh we clapped our hands we banged the
plates we did this that somehow we
brought the country together to respond
to it
the way we should well there was a lot
of pain but still
we responded and handled it better than
most other nations
further for the concentration of
population we have
i think we handle it exceptionally well
but by the you know in the last 14
months
that has eroded now people think they
are quite invincible
or you know most people are immortal
this is the problem
they think other people die they don't
understand they die
you know so this time around one thing
is a virus is also much stronger
for whatever reasons of its own and uh
people have become little lacks while we
are paying a price
where you know the death the mortality
rate is extremely high
the level of suffering that's happening
there is no way any nation can provide
a hospital bed for its whole population
at a time
you know it's simply impossible to do
that so
whatever war footing people are handling
it but this
is going to damage the economy in a
serious way it is going to disrupt
lifestyles and life
in so many ways overall so many people
have lost their lives
every day at least 12 to 15 people that
i know well are dying
every day it's terrible
and you don't get to see the body from
the hospital it goes straight to the
crematorium
and you know there's no closure in your
mind
because you didn't see them either in
the hospital bed or in the
cremation they just somebody else
government is doing all this
you are just at home receiving messages
your father is dead your mother is dead
this kind of stuff this is not easy time
for people
this is a time we must understand our
karma our present karma is most
important
when i tell the word karma people always
think in terms of
fate no karma means action my action my
responsibility
right now all right the global situation
is in a certain way
now how i respond will determine this
the most unique and a positive thing
about this pandemic is
it is not being spread by mice or birds
or some other mosquito or something else
like other diseases were happening
this is the only carrier in this
pandemic is a human being
if human beings as a generation of
people
if we respond consciously well
the virus will be over people ask me at
that time
in the ma in the march of uh 2020
sadhguru what is the solution
see i've been telling you for for 40
years you must learn to sit still
you know it's very important if 14 days
all of us simply just sit down in the
world
not interact not go with anybody not go
anywhere in 14 days it'll be over the
pandemic
but can you get the population to do
that oh
when the pandemic is raging somebody
wants to have a haircut somebody wants
to drink a beer
somebody wants to go and meet somebody
endless number of compulsions
because of compulsive reactions being
human has become such a liability
the greatest thing about a human being
is we can conduct
everything that we do consciously see in
many ways if you look at yourself or
if you look at human nature what are we
doing we are born like any other
creature
we grow up like any anybody else any
other
creature we survive we eat
we reproduce we die one day just like
any other creature
only significance is we can do all this
consciously
that's a world of difference that is all
it is
if you don't do that if you don't go do
it consciously
i think evolution has been wasted upon
you
really wasted so karma means this
this is a moment from unconsciousness to
consciousness
this is a moment from fanciful belief
systems to responsibility
this is very very important my life is
my karma means i'm 100 responsible
100 responsible for the way i am right
now
i'm peaceful i'm joyful i'm miserable
i'm
in a horrible state everything is me if
i know this
i will naturally live my life in such a
way it will be elevated
but if i think because of you i am
miserable
well one thing i will stay miserable
another thing is if my misery gets too
bad i want to kill you
this is what is happening this is what
is happening in the world
every day either i want to kill myself
or i want to kill you now who is
predicting
a mental and a health pandemic they're
predicting a suicide pandemic this
already happened
in japan in 2020 the number of people
who died of suicide
is way higher than the number of people
who died of the virus
so we don't really need virus help
we can do it ourselves we're pretty good
on self-help
we don't really need any external
situations to cause misery to ourselves
when we cause misery to ourselves and if
i think my misery is because of you
i want you dead if i can't have you dead
maybe i'll kill myself or i'll do
something else you see every other day
somebody is going and just
shooting random people why extreme
misery
isn't it deep levels of anger
frustration is there to such a point
you don't mind who you kill you know
it is not even a target point that you
want to kill you don't mind who you kill
men women children anybody you can kill
simply because that is the level of
misery
instead of looking at the violence that
is happening we must look at the level
of misery and frustration
and degradation that's happened within
the human being why is this
because we are always thinking somebody
did this to us isn't it
if you see my life is my karma you will
take charge of your life
you will do the best that you can do
with this one
maybe we can't fix the whole world we
can fix this one
isn't it how important is service
in all of this in terms of having a
happy life a joyful life
your karma that it's not just for you
but it's that it's contributing to
somebody else service
uh i mean i
contributing to other lives is different
but i let me i don't like this word
service so let me demolish that first
suppose for example let's say
you have you have a child i thought
right yeah
yes so when your child is growing up
the more opportunity you get to do
things for him or her
the better it is right
do you think every time you pick up your
child every time you feed him every time
you
educate him you pay for him do you think
you're doing service
uh i would i mean i'm helping him i'm
contributing to his life but
how would how do you see it no are you
uh
do you see it as a great privilege that
you can carry your child and he's
with you and you're enjoying that whole
thing or are you thinking you're doing
some great service for him
i guess a bit of both but i i
probably will default to just i'm
helping him more than some great service
if you're denied this that you cannot
help him
will you be happier no
so it's it's a joyful thing for you to
do
so you're being served not him
sure if the child did not come most
people wouldn't know what to do with
themselves
is this this bundle of joy came into
their life and their lives have
transformed
because most idiots have forgotten by
the time they're 30 how to be joyful
when the child comes without knowing
they will sing without knowing they will
dance without knowing they'll swallow
crawl under the table which they never
did all their life
so i'm saying your child if you do
something it's an act of love
but if a child on the street is there
and if you do something it's a service
simply because heart is bereft of love
isn't it if you have love in your heart
you can't serve anybody because it's a
great privilege you got an opportunity
to do something for someone
it is it's a great enhancement to you it
is not a service to somebody
because what can you do
you can give food you can give money you
can give education this this
this is not yours you came with nothing
you'll go with nothing what is here
you're only redistributing right
did you come with something you won did
i come with something i came with uh
no it came with an intent to get no
empty-handed
you are born empty-handed you will go
empty-handed all right
so here what is here i'll put it here
what is there i'll put it there and i'm
thinking i'm making a great contribution
no no it's a privilege that you can move
things in a way that it works
that's all so because people
have made themselves in such a way that
their idea of love
is only for what belongs to them they
must own it
if they have to love something they have
to own it because of this rudimentary
idea
they can do service having said that
does it mean to say
you cannot contribute your every moment
of your life must be a contribution
every moment contribution need not
necessarily mean only money
only some useful activity the very way
you exist can be a contribution
if you walk on the street if you meet 10
people on the way
you know total strangers if you meet
them on the way you can either leave a
positive impact upon them
or a negative impact upon them or let it
just pass by
most people are passing by like their
statues
like this suddenly they go home and
they're loving
i don't know how they do it at least you
must practice on the street i'm saying
with the trees and the clouds and the
people
because what you do is question of
capability competence resource so many
things
but how you are is just your willingness
isn't it
if you fix how you are if you are a
loving and joyful human being
everything that you can do you will do
it's not for me to determine what you
should do
whatever you can do you will do whatever
i can do i will do
right now if i am constipated in my
thought or emotion
now what i can do i will not do that's a
tragedy of life
when there is no love in your heart what
you can do you will not do
what you cannot do if you do not do
there is no problem
but if you do not do what you can do
you're a disaster isn't it
and service is a terribly burdensome
thing
because you will keep accounts of
everything that you did and you will
suffer when people don't pay back
when people don't show gratitude to you
but when you see it's a privilege that
it's happening through you
you don't expect anything it's wonderful
because it's a great privilege things
are happening through you
it ties in like i'm thinking like how
did
consciousness versus compulsiveness
right i think compulsively we're not
we're not living that life right we're
not contributing to others we're not
loving others we're not loving ourselves
we're not being conscious about it
how do we how do we move from
compulsiveness which is
the default operating system or software
like you you call it
to consciousness let's understand
because both these words are
hugely used karma and consciousness both
are hugely hugely used
all over generally in a very loose
manner just about in any
any way people like they're using it
let's understand this karma means
it is an accumulated impression that we
have gathered within ourselves with
with these four aspects of activity
body mind emotion and energy so this
gathering
is way beyond your understanding or my
understanding because
in a day how many things are happening
means unbelievable
see it's like this experiments have been
conducted like this
suppose you walk on the street let's say
150
yards in those 50 yards there may be 50
different types of smells on the street
you don't consciously notice all this if
something is very strong in a pleasant
way you will notice it if it's very
unpleasant you will notice it
but in between other 48 of those things
you do not notice
but all of them are registered in your
mind and they have a certain
impact on you next time you are
approaching some place
even without knowing suddenly you have a
resistance for that place
you don't know why simply because an
unconscious recording of that smell is
there in your mind and it starts
reacting to that
this is a wonderful survival system
mechanism
but once you become human your life is
not all about survival
if you are like any other creature your
whole life was about survival
once you become human survival is a
small aspect of it
rest of it is about evolving and
blossoming as a human being
if that has to happen then you have to
go beyond your karma
which is instead of saying compulsive
which is a negative word
let's say you're automated with this
memory
with all this memory you're automated
how you will sit
how you will stand how you will speak
how you will respond to various things
everything is automated this makes life
easy karma makes your life
easy if you stand upon it if you sink
into it it'll make you suffer
so is karma a bad thing no such thing
you should i have only pleasant karma no
such thing
if you have a lot of unpleasant karma
within you you should become very wise
if you are conscious you will become
very wise with unpleasant karma
but if you are not conscious this
unpleasantness which happened 10 years
ago
will make you suffer now most human
beings are like this
what happened 10 years ago they're still
suffering what may happen day after
tomorrow they're already suffering
they are not suffering life they are
suffering two
most fantastic faculties that human
beings have
a vivid sense of memory and a fantastic
sense of imagination
both they're suffering without these two
things you cannot even call yourself a
human being
our life is rich only because of our
karmic memory
every little thing that's happened in
your life from your birth
in some way you remember with all these
bits and pieces
you are a certain concoction which may
be interesting
which may be experientially good or
above all it's complex
what is complex can be made into
something very beautiful
or very ugly depending upon how where
you stand in it
if you stand upon it you look great if
you sink into it you look terrible
this is the nature of karma so karma is
not against you
it is making life easy for you survival
processes can be automated a few things
but if you become fully automatic that
means
there is no point living tomorrow
because tomorrow there is no possibility
you are fully automated
so just to maintain that balance that
you are always in touch with your karma
you are on top of it
but you are not sinking into it for this
you need to be conscious
if you're not conscious you will become
fully swallowed by your own automation
you'll tend to become like a machine
this has happened to a whole lot of
adults
when they were children they were
exuberantly alive slowly they become
automatic machines
just like that they're going about going
to the office coming back home doing
everything as
it's programmed within themselves
programmed by themselves
but still whether somebody programs it
for you or you program it for yourself
once you was fixed into the program
you're just an automation
you're reducing millions of years of
evolution
into a machine how's that you use an
example in the book of if somebody
is compulsively eating to
take a step back to sit down to just
wait
a few minutes and then as you train that
that few minutes can become a few hours
can become a few days and then you kind
of lose the
compulsivity around it is that the
guidance like if you can find something
that you feel
you're not living consciously around to
just
sit with it and feel the discomfort and
reflect on it
uh don't reflect on it just just give it
a little time see right now
you said something that i don't like now
i want to abuse you
just just wait just a minute you wait
and you will see you yourself will see
how senseless that
that reaction is but most people don't
have that little time
you say something i'll say something you
know immediately because
there is no time gap that means time is
not needed for consciousness
but if you are very unconsciously
reacting or you're very compulsively
reacting
a little space will make a difference
essentially
this space is about this because we were
talking about hunger
see hunger has a certain very
fundamental level of compulsiveness
because it's our survival
okay essentially we are here today
talking
because we have eaten all right if we
don't eat it doesn't work so
there is an instinct within us when food
comes when we are hungry
everything else disappears we just want
to gobble it today because for most
people food is coming five ten times a
day
they may not notice that but if they are
if they have not eaten for five days
you will see they will eat like animals
gobble everything that comes their way
because it is instinctually built in
every cell in our body
because when we are hungry it's not just
the stomach crying every cell in our
body is crying
you need to eat so that works into a
very compulsive intention
to grab the food and take it so when
that is happening if you can sit
for two minutes without you know
hankering for it it'll do wonders to you
so you know
the gautama the buddha went to the
extent of saying
when you're very hungry and in need of
food
if you give away your food to somebody
you will become stronger
is it that we don't we over judge
ourselves that the two minutes doesn't
count the two minutes is nothing
we don't give ourselves enough uh
praise or encouragement for having
waited two minutes because it seems so
small compared to two hours or two days
or two weeks
so you don't have to try to do two hours
two minutes is good enough once you
become conscious
then what you do with it whether you eat
you don't eat or how to how you handle
it
everything will be in your hands i am
not saying you don't eat
all i'm saying is once you become human
you're eating you're breathing you're
sitting you're standing
everything should become conscious if it
becomes conscious
you will see there is no ordinary human
being on this planet
every human being being will become an
extraordinary
human being everybody has this
possibility the only problem is
right now they are programmed software
so you're really in the software
business yes in a way
the next building is here if you could
if you can write unconscious software
and today suffer that
is it not possible that you can write
your software consciously
that's all i'm saying you wrote your
software unconsciously as a child as a
youth
something something drove you and you
wrote that kind of software for yourself
now can you not write it you write your
software consciously
definitely you can if you write a song
conscious software
will you write a blissful software for
yourself or a miserable software
i hope the answer is blissful
[Laughter]
no if you write it for yourself
definitely you will write a blissful
software isn't it i hope so yeah because
blissfulness doesn't
is not a goal blissfulness is not a goal
it's an ambulance in which life
flourishes
so if karma is inside us from the
beginning
and it's this collective weight
potentially of all the experiences that
we've had to where we are now
that could be a pretty strong software
in the wrong direction that we're
running on autopilot
what are some of the daily practices we
need to do because when we start
building our
our own software that's blissful it's
going up against this big
mountain that we've built for ourselves
over our entire history
that you know today one day compared to
you know 41 years of evan
it almost doesn't it's not a fair fight
so so what are some of the things that
we have to do
daily to build up our confidence level
that this new software is working
see the past whatever
this 41 years doesn't exist anywhere
except in your own memory
isn't it does it exist anywhere
no in existence so it's not
existentially true
now you're talking about fighting with
that which does not exist
if you fight with that which does not
exist of course
it's an endless fight
if you fight with that which exists
either you will win or you will lose
something will happen
but if you start fighting with that
which does not exist
well you are condemned for life to fight
for nothing so you cannot fight this 41
years there's no need to fight i'm
talking about standing upon it because
this experience cannot be lost whether
good things happen to you bad things
happen to you it doesn't matter
this experience cannot be lost because
it's vital
but whatever comes our way what will we
make out of it
this choice we must retain see what the
world throws at you
is not your choice it is the times in
which we exist
well there are a whole lot of
inspirational teachers in the world
today unfortunately
who keep on saying you can do what you
want in this world
all the best for them they will learn
slowly probably they are not as old as
me
[Laughter]
they will learn hard ways and you know
these are silly things being said
everywhere the world is the way it is
today because of the times in which we
are born isn't it
if you and me were here a thousand years
ago would we would we be zooming each
other
no no so i'm saying we are doing this
not because we are some two great
individuals doing something it is the
times in which we are born which
facilitates so many things for us
now how we conduct this
is entirely ours what the world throws
is not entirely ours we have a small
stake in that
it's not completely our peace there's a
larger piece many forces are acting upon
that
but how we experience it is 100
hours whatever the world throws at me
will i go through it joyfully and
miserably is entirely my choice
there is simply no two ways about that
so karma
means when i'm talking about crafting
your destiny
people are thinking destiny means i must
go here i must get this much money i
must do this i must do that
see it's like this you know i used to be
regular at the economic forum even
probably this year i will make it
because i moved it to singapore this
time i don't know with this virus
whether i'll be able to make it or not
but anyway so this is a place where
nearly 800 to 1000 all billionaires
there
yeah particularly one year 2008 i think
when there was a certain
downfall in the uh you know like a
little depression
in the world's economy all these
billionaires i saw were in different
states of misery because they were a few
billions less than what they were three
months ago
so i was talking to them and i said see
whether it's a billion dollar or it's
something simple
let's say you're in some remote village
in africa or india somewhere
you have one calf or you have two cows
you lost
one you will be
absolutely miserable because you lost
one cow
you have two billion dollars you lost
one billion you will be absolutely
miserable
do you believe the man who lost one cow
his misery is nothing because it's the
cow's
price in the marketplace is not
comparable to one billion dollars
no no he will be equally miserable or
more miserable
in the marketplace one billion dollars
and a cow you cannot compare
but in human experience it's the same
things
so our question is not about what
happens in terms of quantities in your
life
the question is about how you experience
your life
if you are experiencing your life in a
very pleasant manner
the unfolding of your being happens your
genius will unfold
the best capabilities will unfold
everything that you can do in this world
you will do
depending on the times 1000 years ago
you came here and you want to zoom me
no you have to come in 21st century to
do that right
so i am saying what we do is not all
ours
but how we experience this life is 100
hours you mentioned the word destiny and
it's in the subtitle
here you know a yogi's guide to crafting
your destiny
at the beginning way back at this
interview you talked it you mentioned
the word fate
and i think a lot of people feel like
well i'm fated to do this
or because i was born in this year i'm
gonna be
this astrology and zodiac science and
all this stuff
how does what's your take on karma
destiny and how does that connect to
what i'm fated to do when astrology say
again we can instead of going to a new
analogy or an example we can go back to
the same thing
let us say whatever is your star sign
now you were born in the same star
sign hundred years ago or a thousand
years ago would you be doing the same
things
no no so
on your sign i don't know how many there
are only 12 signs right
so there's seven points no the zodiac
signs are 12.
so what is astronomy has been converted
into astrology
well certain predictions certain
guessing guesswork
and partial predictions as to which way
the winds are moving
you can maybe say something but a human
being
a conscious human being is beyond these
things this is why i'm talking about
karma right now
that planets and stars which are
inanimate objects in the universe
should not decide the destiny of who you
are
because you are a conscious human being
if you are a conscious human being
you will determine the destiny of who
you are in india there is a tradition
that if you go to an astrologer if you
say
i am on a spiritual path i've been
initiated into something
by by my guru he will refuse to look at
your
charts because he says this is not
relevant
because once you're in the spiritual
path what it means is
you have decided to take charge of your
life you become conscious
now all the indications of where it will
go what it is it's like this
see if you're an ancient mariner if you
are or if you were an ancient
mariner winds would decide where you
will go
today your nuclear-powered ship
you decide where you go this is the
difference between consciousness
and fatalistic way of existence i love
it
i know we're getting close to the end
and i could talk to you forever is there
is there one story that's come
from the launch of the book somebody
who's read it somebody close to you
that it's had an impact on their life
that you'd be able to share
i think it's best they share isn't it
i can tell you a story from shankaran
pillai's life
you know this guy no you haven't met him
oh okay
if you read further into the book you
will meet this guy his name is shankaran
pillai
shankaran pillai is like john smith
okay in the west
shankaran pillai wanted to file for
divorce
so the lawyer took the case and uh
then he looked at this and said why do
you want to divorce
he said my wife has terrible table
manners
and children are all picking up this
terrible table manner so i want to
divorce her then the lawyer asked how
long you been married
he said 23 years what
23 years you had no problem with her
table manners
now what is the problem now he said well
i did
not know that she had bad manners only
yesterday afternoon
i bought this book on etiquette
and after reading it i see her manners
are terrible
well you're reading a book on karma
i love it but a lot of people are saying
it's doing wonderful things to them
let me see you know
many people are talking about it but
it's just a few days since they got the
books
uh it will definitely have impact
because
i i'm not trying to pat my own back but
i think unfortunately there has been a
deep
deep deep levels of misunderstanding of
what is karma
not only in the western societies even
in the eastern society even in india
serious misunderstandings as if this is
a way of fixing your life
okay your karma fixes your life no your
karma may orient you in a certain
direction
it doesn't fix you it's for you to ride
that wheel of karma
it's called usually referred to as a
wheel of karma because
anything that is uh you know fixed
software can go only in cycles
so it starts going in cycles if it is
spinning in the same place then it's a
frustrating wheel
if you know how to write it to a place
that you want to go
then it's a fantastic vehicle that's
what karma is
well the book is karma this is what it
looks like you can see it here you can
see behind him
the link to get it is in the description
below i've got my copy
i hope you pick up yours as well as
always thank you for the wisdom the time
the energy
the joy appreciate you wonderful
if you want to see the last one-on-one i
did with sadguru check it out
right there next to me i think you'll
love it continue to believe
and i'll see you there nobody can cause
mental pain to you
it is you in reaction to something that
happens around you
it is time you take away the nonsense
that's happening within you